ladies you haven't seen in the film
where there's a confessional and you're
letting her know as a sister that it was
about competition and you're unaware
have you ever had someone in your acting
career let you know the same and you
were taken aback you were surprised that
it was more about competition when it
hadn't been that way for you and how did
you handle it um I think many people may
feel to need to compete with me I think
I think no I haven't had that experience
before I don't think I have anything I
it's and perhaps maybe just it's been
there and maybe someone hasn't said it
of course it's a competitive industry
and we're all vying for you know the
same roles and the great jobs but I've
been fortunate enough to work with some
great people particularly Mandy who was
wonderful and there was there is not a
competitive bone in her body she's so
supportive and kind and just such a
great teammate so yeah I haven't you
know really had that experience and in
the work world I haven't either I think
I've really left out that I haven't
encountered anybody in that regard
you know felt the need to be competitive
like the industry pits us all against
one another as women anyway and there's
just there's enough there's enough room
for everybody and just having faith that
like things work out the way they're
supposed to and you should be there to
support and build each other up you know
it was a great scene because I think
thank you were unaware that that was how
it felt to you and vice versa so I was
just curious if because we all know that
it's a competitive town in many respects
to have somebody admit that I think the
competitive world to that we live
nowadays I mean with social media and
everyone sort of looking at like
someone's seemingly perfect life and the
way they're sort of curating things it's
not necessarily real live up and I
picked up daddy remember just stay in
your own lane and do the work and
hopefully good things up yeah that's
good
how much underwater filming time did you
have this is almost all on your mind
yeah we had one week above water and the
rest of
than woman yeah so I would say about 17
weeks underwater yeah you're the last
yeah thank you about it now I call that
was a long time yeah I can't believe we
did that we really celebrated at the end
we did because this was unfamiliar
territory for everyone involved for us
as actors for the filmmakers even for
the crew I mean the crew that we worked
with were and experienced underwater
crew but they usually are just used for
bits and pieces of film for like the
underwater portions of certain films so
they had never been a part of like an
entire production that rested on their
shoulders and was their responsibility
so it was new territory and I think
that's what was equal parts exciting and
also daunting about something like this
and this was shot in the UK's on some of
the underwater scene Hank walk was in
the UK and then a little bit more tank
work and some of the exteriors were at
all of the exteriors are that we're in
the Dominican Republic so how would that
work you would do a few pages of
dialogue and then come up I mean I'm
just wondering how did all that we kind
of were flying by the seat of our pants
so the general rule was when our air got
to a certain point we were going to
surface
and refill our tanks and then we'd all
go back down so it usually depending on
the amount of heavy breathing or
screaming or like physical exertion we
could usually last like an hour on a
hank maybe a little longer yeah so we'd
go down for like an hour at a time and
we wouldn't surface again until our
tanks were we're ran up right now and
neither of you had scuba dived before no
nothing we had a tiny bit of like a
crash course before he started shooting
where we had one open ocean dive with
our director here in California like off
the coast of Ventura so we we did two
open ocean dives that day on that
particular trip but that was it in terms
of like having any diving experience
yeah it was not yeah I was like okay are
we breaking the law no way we survived
there perfect so any tips one tip for an
actor that's doing that type of work
diving yeah go to the bathroom first or
get your boxing plan unfortunately just
learn low when you gotta get your
underwater ahead would Gloria Lauer
apps to go to the bathroom that's unreal
and I would say make sure that you're
eating enough yeah like because you
really expend a lot of energy and you're
getting enough sleep
prepare to be exhausted heads besides
yeah okay good thank you